docteur carvin c'est avec nos bons soirs
dr weiss bons sont pas prises alors
depuis le début les experts et vous et
d'autres médecins vous dites l'immunité
naturelle vous les expliquer tout cela
dans ma quand le premier ministre en
parle dans une conférence de presse
quotidienne comme ça les gens se disent
mais là on nous a dit de nous enfermer
pendant ces semaines on nous dit qu'il
faut attraper la maladie
bon pour vous il ya aux héros
contradictions mais donnez-moi votre
explication alors la première phase
pourquoi est ce qu'on a essayé de
continuer les gens c'est parce que on
avait zéro protection et si on n'avait
pas fait on aurait eu le même nombre de
cas que sur une période on va dire de
neuf mois ou 10 mois mais concentrée sur
une très faible période
je vous donne un exemple imaginez que
vous avez 100 1000 québécois qui vont
être affectés
on va dire c'est juste un exemple mais
que vous en avez ces cent mille sont
infectés sur une période de 10 mois ou
ces cent mille vont être affectés sur
une période de un mois
au bout du compte vous allez avoir le
même nombre de gens infectés mais si
vous en avez trop pendant une courte
période de temps parmi les 100 milles
s'il y en a quinze mille qui sont très
malades qui ont besoin d'être
hospitalisés ont besoin d'aller aux
soins intensifs on sera pas capable on
va être submergé pour traiter ces
gens-là adéquatement
alors que si vous les gars l'avoir sans
vie vous en avez dit 1000 par mois sont
affectés à ce moment là au lieu d'en
avoir
quinze mille vous en aurez 1500 et ça
c'est très absorbant et c'est d'ailleurs
des chefs qui ressemble beaucoup à la
réalité ce que vous dites là on passe un
peu c'est un petit peu on essaie de
faire quand on essaie dé talent et si
vous voulez en parler d'aplatir on est
ici plus qu'à aplatir c'est d'étaler une
cour puis en même temps on construit une
immunité à l'intérieur de la population
une immunité qui va nous permettre
éventuellement d'avoir à ces mots
protéger pour que le virus ne se
transmet tu sais ça là on est rendu à
l'étape donc où on peut dire plus
ouvertement en tout cas c'est le message
on veut mettre la lumière sur cette
partie du message que éventuellement
plus de gens santé lors ont eu le virus
- et le virus pourra circuler librement
dans la société
alors quand on a déjà dit
un virus a besoin d' infecté quelqu'un
pour continuer sa préparation ci n'est
plus capable d'infecter quelqu'un il a
plus de clients
il rencontre un cul de sac et donc il va
pas continuer sa propagation dans une
société
ça va dépendre que ce qu'on appelle le
r0 le r0 coelacanthe c'est le nombre de
gens qui vont être infectées par un cas
donc si par exemple un 1/4 fait deux
autres personnes
le r0 et a26 l'infect 3 c3 et ainsi de
suite
la rougeole est une maladie extrêmement
contagieuse qui peut affecter 15 17
personnes à un cas de rougeole ça en
donne 15 15 15 secondes est si on a avec
au début ils ont d'autres en 10 et 2 3
maintenant peut-être même 4 en termes de
r 0 qu'est ce que ça signifie un
signifie que chacun des gens va infecter
quatre personnes et donc par rapport à
ça ce que ça signifie ça signifie que le
risque d'avoir rapidement à 4 personnes
beaucoup de gens immunisés dans une
population va augmenter une fois que les
gens sont immunisés la transmissibilité
du virus va devenir de moins en moins
efficace 1
si par exemple vous êtes 100 personnes
il y en a juste une qui est protégé le
virus il à 99 clients si vous êtes 100
personnes bien à 60 qui sont protégés
lui réussit lui reste que 40 clients
donc ça transmises transmissibilité
devient beaucoup moins
et d'ailleurs pour qu'on considère une
société bien protégée
est ce que dans votre esprit c'est
encore 60% ou 70% ou 80 pour ça alors
arrêtez ça dépend du r 0 c'est ça il ya
un calcul mathématique
au début on disait que le r0 à dison 2.3
ça vous dit qu'à 56 % de la population
la transmission du virus va commencer à
tomber le vérisme à 5,1 devenir de moins
en moins transmissibles dans une
population
alors c'est sûr que plus la quantité de
gens infectés est guéri va être élevé
moins de virus aura des clients si vous
voulez dans alors habituellement dès
qu'on commence à dépasser 50%
c'est clair que la transmissibilité du
virus devient beaucoup moins bonne c'est
sa pire on est actuellement on ne le
sait pas parce qu'on n'a pas encore
assez de tests sérologiques non on doit
être
autour de 2,3 peut-être un peu plus à
montréal mais guère plus que ça puisque
les gens sont restés confinés
on ne sait pas vraiment regardé à new
york qui parle de la ville de new york
et une étude qui dirait que c'est pas un
peu près 21% de la population
alors c'est sûr que new york c'était la
zone chaude mais qu'on parlait de l'état
de new york autour d'eux peut-être 16%
mais c'est clair qu'on a encore des
faible pourcentage de population
affectée 30 pour ça que graduellement ce
qu'on commence à dire aux gens c'est que
oui on va laisser graduellement le virus
se promener et on va espérer que des
gens plus faibles plus à risque ne
soient pas atteints évidemment c'est
toujours le même principe très bien
docteur j'ai trois questions du public
plus ce soir réalisé oui à l'usinage des
coquettes très bien alors injecté une
infime quantité de virus à une personne
permettrait-il à cette personne de
développer des anticorps
ça s'appelle un vaccin alors vous voulez
pas injecter 1 un virus vivants parce
que si vous injecter un virus vivants
vous allez rendre cette personne-là
malade et donc c'est surtout pas ça
qu'on veut faire même si c'est un virus
respiratoires ce qu'on fait dans un
vaccin c'est comprend une partie du
virus qui reste la plus constante
possible un qui reste tout le temps la
même quand vous injecte qui ne vous
provoquera pas la maladie mais qui va
apprendre à votre système
à vous défendre c'est comme si je vous
disais regarder je veux pas vous donner
une auto mais je vais vous donner
suffisamment d'éléments pour que vous
reconnaissiez que quelque chose qui ait
un volant et quatre roues c'est
probablement une auto que quand vous
allez voir quelque chose qui ressemble à
ça
spécifiquement vous allez faire des
anticorps et vous allez vous protéger
donc c'est ça l'idée d'un vaccin très
bien si une personne et c'est un
symptôme est asymptomatique peut-elle
transmettre le virus seulement pendant
14 jours où elle peut être infecté plus
longtemps ses revenus mille fois ça oui
alors on ne sait pas exactement encore
mais ce concept et qui est très peu de
données là dessus à une étude en
allemagne qui a démontré que les gens
qui étaient plus symptomatique depuis au
moins 48 heures qui avait vraiment plus
de symptômes probablement que ce jour de
ces gens là après environ sept jours ne
sont plus infectieux donc généralement
c'est ce qu'on pense n'y en a pas en
temps les données pour vous donner
réponse de façon exacte probablement que
si vous avez plus de symptômes vous êtes
totalement la pratique vous faites plus
de fièvre
sauf que là tout brûle à tout pour
pouvoir persiste et des fois pendant des
semaines mais ça c'est pas grave mais si
vous avez plus de vraiment de maladies
aiguës oralement que sept jours après sa
prise de devenir infectieux pour les
autres est faible les enfants les
enfants vous demande jacob joseph et
noah 8 ans 12 ans 13 ans nous aimerions
savoir si nos cochons d'inde peuvent
attraper la crevette 19 et si oui
pourrait-il nous la transmettre des
ronds peut transférer son chien ou chat
et ces maisons là on vous pose la
question sur les cochons d'inde
alors je ne sais pas les chiens non les
chiens dont les fellahs il semblerait
qu'ils soient plus susceptibles aux
virus vous avez eu des chars peut-être
qu'ici et là qui ont été décrits un
tigre même qu'ils auraient été
contaminés les cochons d'inde
honnêtement je n'ai pas la réponse à
vous donner dr weiss merci beaucoup pea
en 30 secondes
ce n'est pas parce que là on va beaucoup
parler de déconfinement puis de que des
gens sentent qu'ils peuvent avoir la
maladie ce qui veulent mieux nous
collectivement nous protéger que c'était
une erreur de nous confiner comme vous
l'avez si bien expliqué ce avait été
trop vite les appuis thouars étaient
débordés regardez la suède 1 utilisé un
petit peu cette technique le royaume uni
à ses débuts avait utilisé un peu cette
approche différente
et puis ça n'a pas été un succès le
royaume uni est vite revenu sur ses pas
et la suède
il ya un très grand débat actuellement
sur en suède à ce sujet là avec beaucoup
plus de morts qu au québec plus ou moins
et une population qui quand même un peu
de choses près et dans l'ordre de
grandeur du québec des dix ans deux
millions de plus d'habitants merci
docteur merci beaucoup de vos lumières
bonne suite à l'hôpital bon courage pour
nous joindre voici nos adresses
mesdames et messieurs pour poser une
question à dr weiss entre autres on a
ajouté un numéro de téléphone pour ceux
qui n'ont pas accès à un ordinateur pour
internet 5 preuve 7 43 00 57 43 00 si
vous êtes à l'extérieur et grande région
de montréal fait là un 8-3
[Musique]